LIKE THE ROADS ARE NICE THERE,
BUT COME ON.
STAY RIGHT THERE, JUDGE JEANINE
AND CHRIS.
TIME FOR MY ANKLE PART 2 A OCS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> I HAVE SOME BAD NEWS FOR YOU,
AOC HAS INSOMNIA.
AND SHE THINKS THIS ONE THING
SHOULD KEEP YOU UP AS WELL SO.
>> YOU KNOW MOM IS ON VACATION,
I WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AT 3:30 IN THE MORNING
JUST CONCERNED ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION,
DOES THAT BOXED MAC AND CHEESE
THAT SHE WAS MAKING COME WITH A
TINFOIL HAT?
LIKE BERNIE WITH HIS COMMENTS
ABOUT THE CHINESE, AOC'S LATE
NIGHT MUSING THE TRUE AGENDA OF
THE CLIMATE CHANGE CREW.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT JUST
PUTTING OVER PEOPLE'S ROADS BUT
CHANGING THE CONSUMPTION.
THIS IS ABOUT LIVING OUR WHOLE
LIFE IN A WAY THAT IS MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND INHUMANE.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO INTO COWS
AND PLANE TRAVEL, BUT WE NEED TO
CHANGE OUR LIVES.
>> Laura: THERE YOU HAVE IT.
AS I TOLD YOU PART 1 OF THE
ANGLE, THIS ISN'T ABOUT SCIENCE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT FACTS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT GOVERNMENT
CONTROLLING ALMOST EVERY ASPECT
OF YOUR LIFE.
BUT THE LIBERALS WILL NOT CHANGE
THEIR LIFESTYLE UNDER THE
SYSTEM.
THEY WILL NOT CHANGE THEIR
LIFESTYLE ONE IOTA.
IN ANY SOCIALIST TODAY THE VERY
RICH WAY OF THE TOP AND THE
STOOGES AND GOVERNMENT DICTATE
THE TERMS FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
THEN THERE IS PUNY, BELEAGUERED
MIDDLE-CLASS, AND THE REST ARE
THE POOR PEOPLE.
LEONARDO DiCAPRIO, HE IS STILL
GOING TO DO MOVIE SHOOTS ON A
G5.
>> YOU THINK OUR ECONOMY
OVERHAULING 2D CARBONIZED MP THE
PLANET WILL BE EXPENSIVE?
TRY NOT ORGANIZING THE ECONOMY
AND ALLOWING SEA LEVEL TO RISE
EVERY COASTAL CITY TO GO
UNDERWATER EVERY MIDWESTERN CITY
EXPERIENCING DROUGHT ON A LEVEL
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN.
THAT IS GOING TO BE WAY MORE
EXPENSIVE.
>> Laura: THAT MEANS OBAMA'S
WILL BE WAY OUT OF THEIR HOUSE
IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD ALL'S WELL,
WOW!
DON'T SWEAT THE $93 TRILLION
PRICE TAG FOR THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
IT WILL PRACTICALLY PAY FOR
ITSELF.